اهلا بكم الى برنامج النقاش كما تعلمون
اتخذت اليوم الولايات المتحده والمانيا
وعده دول غربيه قرارا هاما فيما يتعلقوا
بتسليح اوكرانيا
وافقتا على تزويد كيف بدبابات مقاتله
ثقيله ذات سمعه حسنه في ساحات القتال
برلين سترسل لها دبابات اليوبار اثنين
واشنطن سترسل لكيف ابره فرنسا
عدد الدبابات الثقيله التي ستحصل عليها
كاف لا يتخطى حتى الان العشرات ومع ذلك
تراهن اوكرانيا بشده على هذه الدبابات
لتغيير مسار الامور ميدانيه فما فائده هذه
الدبابات تكتيكيا ما الذي ستغير في
الميدان كيف سترد موسكو على قيام المانيا
بتسليم اليوبارد اثنين الى كافه موسكو
حضرات مرارا برلين من مغبه القيام بذلك
كيف سيكون شكل المواجهه بين روسيا والغربه
المواجهه ربما السياسيه حتى الان كيف
سيكون شكل هذه المواجهه لاحقا بعد هذا
التطور بعد هذا المنعطف سنتحدث عن ذلك مع
ضيوف برنامج النقاش اليوم مرحبا بالاستاذ
عصام ملكاوي استاذ دراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه معنا من عمان من العاصمه
الاردنيه نرحب من برلين الاستاذ شبرما
ياسين الكاتب والصحفيه المختص في الشغل
الاوروبيه ونرحب ايضا من مدينه اطلانتا
الامريكيه
باسحاق عندك يعني الاكاديمي والباحث في
ادارات النزاعات الدوليه اهلا بكم جميعا
قبل ان نبدا النقاش دعونا نستمع الرئيس
الامريكي وهو يعلن اليوم هذا هذه عن هذه
الخطوه الهامه جدا خطوه يبدا كفى بدباباتي
ابراز
المتحده سترسل 31 دبابه ابرامز الى
اوكرانيا اي ما يعادل كتيبه اوكرانيه
كامله
في العالم كما انها معقده للغايه من ناحيه
التشغيل والصيانه لذلك سنوفر لاوكران ايضا
المعدات اللازمه للحفاظ على فعاليتها هذه
الدبابات في ساحه المعركه كما سنبدا في
تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه في اسرع وقت ممكن
استاذ انديانا سابدا معك هل تعتبر اننا
اليوم من خلال قرار الغربيين بارسال احدث
واقوى دباباتهم الى اوكرانيا اننا امام
تحول في الحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا
اعتقد ان يعني ارسال دبابات الابرز
بالكميه التي حددها الرئيس قبل ساعه من
الان ااه حيث يبلغ يعني اعدادها حوالي 30
او 31 دبابه لن تشكله يعني همم تغير من
قواعد اللعبه
لان ذلك همم اعتقد انه جاءك تحفيز للمانيا
لكي ترسل
الدباباتها همم اثنين لانه ما الوضع شرطا
انه لم يرسل الدبابات الا اذا ارسلت باسم
متحده
همم من الناحيه العسكريه لا اعتقد انه
سيغير اي شيء على ارض الواقع باستثناء انه
سيزيد من
المعنويات لدى الجيش الاوكراني والمقاتلين
الاوكراني انهم يعني قد حصل على اسلحه
يعتبر نسبيا همم نوعيه وبالتالي همم هذا
الهدف ما يتعلق في الميدان وفي مسار
المعركه بالنسبه للسياسه فاعتقد ان هذه
الرساله سياسيه اكثر منها رساله عسكريه او
تكتيكيه على ارض الواقع لان الولايات
المتحده والمانيا من خلال ارسال
الدباباتهما كلن على حجم يؤكدان لروسيه
ومن يقف همم في صفها ان الجبهه الغربيه ما
زالت متماسكه وانهم ما زال يقدمون ما اوتي
لهم من قوه ضمن الامكانيات واستراتيجيات
والاجندات التي حددتها كل من الدول
الغربيه
باقل يعني قلبي وضوح اليوم ما عندهم اعلن
عن ارسال الدبابات ابرام
واحده بخصوص وحده سبع همم نتحدث اكثر
بالتفصيل اكثر عن المساء الاساسيه لاحقا
لكن دعنا بالشق العسكري استاذ عصام سليم
الرئيس الاوكراني همم الذي اخبرنا بين
اليوم بان بانه يحتفل بعيد ميلاده
بالمناسبه همم زليسك قال بان دبابات
ابرامز الامريكيه ستبقي اوكرانيا على طريق
النصر بالتالي يعني بالنسبه فعلا هذه
الدبابات همم
ربما ربما تعدل في مسار همم الحرب او
المواجهه مع الروس ما رايك ما رايك بهذا
الكلام
مساء الخير لك وللي ضيوفك الكرام
وللمشاهدين ايضا الحقيقه يعني دعيني بدايه
ابدا واقول نعم انا استاذ علوم سياسيه
واستراتيجيه ولكني خدمت في القوات المسلحه
الاردنيه كضابط دروع لمده طويله من الزمن
ودخلت على دوره في الولايات المتحده سنه
الثمانين وكنت يعني عملت على دبابه
كانت في ذلك الوقت انها رساله سياسيه قبل
ان تكون رساله
تفضل يعني زميلنا السابق عندما تحدث لكن
بالمقابل انا اقول هذه الامور ستسمع ستزيد
من
اشتعال الحرب في اوكرانيا وبالتالي ستكون
الخسائر الاوكرانيه والاوروبيه كبيره جدا
ولذلك المستفيد من هذا التصعيد هي روسيا
لانها عندما تقدم دولته هذه الاسلحه
الغربيه والمعقده بعض الشيء والمطوره الى
اوكرانيا فانها تعطي الفرصه لروسيا لكي
تقدم ما تملكه من اصل لحام متطوره لم تكشف
عنها بعد لذلك دعينا ناخذ مثال على ذلك
عقاب التقطت المداوي للفرقاطه
فقط
الروسيه قبل قبل ذلك استاذ عصام
انها اطلقت صاروخ على بعد 900 كيلو متر من
المحيط الاطلسي واصابت هدفها بدقه اذا
هنالك اسلحه ما زالت في طور عدم الظهور
موجوده لدى روسيا لذلك لماذا تحفز
الولايات المتحده والنيته
الروس لكي يستخدموا اسلحه مدمره اكثر من
اللازم على اخرى
ضابط سابق استاذ عصام وتقول بانك تدربت
على ابرمز واحد طبعا اليوم نحن امام ابرمز
همم لا اعلم اي اي همم
ثلاثه اصبحنا اوكي اوكي
تكتيكيا عسكريا همم على الارض عندما تكون
على الارض ماذا بامكانها ان تفعل
قبل ان نتحدث عن السياسي قبل ان نتحدث عن
السياسه اشرح لي اشرح لي من التقنيه اهميه
هذه الدبابه في عندما سيكون هناك جندي
اوكراني يتواجه فيها معجوند روسي ربما على
الجبهه الشرقيه
مهمه جدا الجندي الاوكراني سيحتاج اقل شيء
الى ثلاثه شهور للتدرب على استخدام هذه
الدبابه الحديثه وهي دبابه معقده يعني
بالمفهوم العسكري ذات تقنيه عاليه جدا
يعني وبالتالي هي همم يعني تسير بوجود
الطائرات بمعنى ان ماتور ها يعني همم نفاس
وبالتالي هي على ارض الواقع هي الدبابه
قادره على ان تقاوم الدبابات الروسيه
عندما سئلنا سال الضابط الامريكي ماذا
تساوي ابرمج واحد مقابل 52 و62 و72 وقال
له واحد بواحده ابدا قال له طيب واحد
بثلاثه
واحد القصه كامله
دباب امريكي
10 د حتى 52
هذا يعني بالمواقيد العسكريه الغربيه
مقابل العقيده العسكريه القتاليه الشرقيه
ان الروسيا قد استخدموا ما يسمى بالكم
والغرب والنيترو يستخدم النوع الكم مقابل
للنوع مثلا دبابه ابراز تكلف بحدود عشره
مليون خمسه مليون كما كم يعني هائل من
المبالغ لكن خمس دبابات روسيه تستطيع ان
تدمر دبابه عبره رمز وبالتالي يعني
الخساره بالمحصل لانها هي هي اكثر على
قوات حلف الناتو المشكله
هنا في التزويد المشكله تكمل في استخدام
الاليه في الارض
صالح العمليات المفتوحه
المبنيه او المناطق شبه المبنيه يعني انا
اسال الاستاذ الكاتب والصحفي المختص
بالشغل همم حول همم يعني همم
الجرعه الالمانيه في النهايه او
بالذهاب وتزويد يعني بهذا الاتجاه وتزويدك
كيف همم ليوبارد اثنين همم
يعني في نفس الوقت الذي تحدثت به الاف
شولدس عن همم تزويدك كيف بهذه الدبابات
كان حريص على ان يقول نحن ايضا نمنع على
نعمل على منع التصعيد والموجهه بين روسيا
وانيتو همم برايك همم المانيا تخاطر كثيره
بهذا الخطوه التي اتخذتها اليوم ام ان كل
الامور محسوبه عدد الدبابات القليل ربما
يعني يشرح لنا شيء
تحياتي لك وتحياتي لضيوفك والمشاهدين قناه
الفرانكات في البدايه المانيا اتخذت هذا
القرار الصعب تحت مظله الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولولا موافقه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بارسال هذه الدبابات عبر انما
اوافق المستشار الالماني
الى اوكرانيا عدد الدبابات المطلوبه من
قبل كيف قرابه 300 دبابه عدد الدبابات
التي ستمنح من قبل المانيا ودول الاتحاد
الاوروبي مجتمعه بعد اخر المانيا تلك
الدول والدبابات الامريكيه لا تتجاوز ال
150 دبابات اي ان هناك 200 دبابه نقص في
الحسابات الاوكرانيه هذه الدبابات
الموجوده الان التي ترسل الى اوكرانيا لن
ترسل قبل ثلاثه الى اربعه اشهر مثل ما شرح
وزير الدفاع الالماني ورئيس شركه
صاحبه الدبابات همم
المانيا الان اصبحت داخله في الحرب
الاوكرانيه بجميع اعضائها بجميع اسلحتها
باستثناء الطائرات
ارسلت ارسلت الدبابات ارسلت المدرعات
النظام الباتريوت اسرح ارسلت انظمه
الصواريخ وصواريخ المحموله بالكذب التي
لدى المانيا ارسلتها الى اوكرانيا
الطائرات بمعنى المانيا دخلت مع اوكرانيا
شريكه في هذا الحرب تحت قياده القوات
المسلحه
الذهاب الى ذلك لوحدها
المسؤولون الروس
كثيرا غاضبون من المانيا بشكل خاص هم لا
يهمهم الموضوع همم الامريكي لديه هو من
غضب كبير من الموضوع الالماني وذلك بعد
موضوع الحرب العالميه الثانيه والجيش هتلر
ترابي من حدود من قبل الجيش الاحمر هذا
الارث التاريخي كان ص على جوز تقبله
وارسال الدبابه ليوباك مقابل الدبابه تي
90 او دي او تي 72 ولكن الضبوط الداخليه
نعم الضغوط الداخليه من قبل حزب القدر
والضغوط الداخليه من قبل الشركاء
الاوروبيين ومن بالاخص من دول اوروبا
الشرقيه جعلت الف شلث وتعيين وزير الدفاع
الجديد الذي اعطى وتم ان الشمس انه لم
يرسل الكثير من الدبابات لاوكرانيا اعطى
زفه من كبيره لارسال هذه الدبابات الى
اوكرانيا واعتقد ان ان هذا سي- سيعطي بعدا
كبيرا
باستهداف
وباستخدام اسلحه اكثر تطورا من قبل
استاذ استاذ اسحاق همم ما الذي يمكن ان
تلجا اليه همم
الاستاذ
عصام لكن ده اني اسال بخصوص نقطه الروسي
تماما تماما فقط استاذ اسحاق همم قل همم
شبر مع ياسين بان روسيا مستاء خصوصا من
المانيا برايك كيف يمكن ان ترد روسيا
تحديدا على المانيا اين يمكن ان تؤلم
المانيا ردا على تزويدها كيف بدبابات
اليوكاريس 2
من المانيا اكثر من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وان الالمان قد تهدد في ارسال
هذه الاسلحه والدبابات النوعيه همم بسبب
الترام التي عاشوها خلال الحرب العالميه
الثانيه والسيطره روسيه على قسم من من
المانيا هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى يعني
اذا ما اخذنا خطوه الى الوراء وقرانا
الامور بكل تجرد وموضوعيه منذ الغاز
الروسي
نجد ان يعني السياسه الغربيه او
استراتيجيه الغربيه التي طبعت في مقارنه
هذا الموضوع هي سياسه او استراتيجته
لكل فعل روسي هناك ماده فعل الغربي
وبالتالي يعني على سبيل المثال عندما غزت
روسيه بالمدرعات الدبابات ارسلت الولايات
المتحده واحد همم صواريخ
اللي هي التي هي مضاده للدروع وعندما بدات
باستخدام الطائرات ارسلت القوه الغربيه
صواريخ الاستنجل وما الى وايضا يعني حتى
مدافع الهاوسن فاذا كل فعل روسي هناك رده
فعل وانا اعتقد ان اردت فعل هذه في ما
يتعلق بارسال الدبابات اتتك همم كنتيجه او
كردت فعل على غزو روسيه لسوليدار
واستخدامها يعني القوه بوحشيه باللجوء الى
بعض المرتزقه بما فيها وبالمناسبه يعني
همم منظمه فاجنر كم منظمه اجراميه دوليه
منذ يومين من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بسبب الوحشي التي ارتكبتها في
الجيوش الاوكرانيه وبالتالي لا شك ان يعني
المنح لهذه الحرب او الاعجاز الروسي
الالكتروني هو منح تصاعدي واعتقد ان يعني
في كل مرحله لدي الى هنا توازن في استخدام
الاسئله من السيارات عندما استخدمت
اوكرانيا المسيارات التركيه بين دار
استخدمت روسيه المسيرات الايرانيه لكي
يصبح هناك توازن وبالتالي اعتقد ان الان
الكره بملعب روسيا هي التي سترد على همم
هذا رده فعل هذه بفعل اخر وهو قد قام انه
كيف كيف يمكن ان يكون هذا الفعل الروسيا
او او الى ماذا يمكن ان تلجا روسيا في همم
لمعاقبه بين مزتين المانيا
لغايه الان كما ذكر سيادتك العميد قبل
قليل انها اطلقت صاروخ المداح حوالي 800
او 900 كم واصابت الهدف بشكل دقيق نعم
هناك اسلحه غير مستخدمه بعد في ساحه
المعركه قد ترجع اليها روسيه كه هذه
الصواريخ او الصواريخ الفرق صوتيات او
ايضا
او صاروخ نووي تكتيكي وليس همم وليس
استراتي مفتوح يعني هذه حرب مفتوحه يعني
كيف ستنتهي من الوقت استغرق بعد لان كل من
الاطراف لديه يعني منافع ولديه ايضا مصادر
القوه ما زالوا متمسكين منها
للاستاذ عصام همم استاذ عصام كنت اولا
ترغب التعليق على ربما شئ ما محدد قبل ان
نطرح عليك سؤال
الحق الحقيقه نعم انه عندما يتم تجويد
اوكرانيا بدبابه اليوباد 2 ليس هي فقط ان
الدبابه ليوبارد اثنين همم من النوع يعني
المتطور جدا جدا على عرض المعركه ولكنها
تتميز بانها قادره على اطلاق قذائف من
اليورانيوم المنظف وبالتالي هذا يعطي
ذريعه همم لدى روسيا بالاعتبار ان هذه حرب
نوويه قذره هنا يكون الرد على المانيا
وعلى اوكرانيا بالذات ان الاصبع النووي
سيكون عدد زناد عندما تقترب هذه بقت
باستخدام هذه القذائف ضد القوات الروسيه
المهاجمه لان روسيا لم تزلم تستخدم مثل
هذه القذائف القذره في اوكرانيا هذا من
النا من الناحيه الناحيه الاخرى ايضا ان
عمليه تجميع الدبابات من حلف الناتو من
البرتغال اربع دبابات من هولندا 12 دبابه
هذا التجميع بالعرف العسكري اعتقد انه لا
يمكن ان يصنع وحده عسكريه مقاتله تستطيع
ان تقابل وتجابه وحدات عسكريه مدربه جاهزه
لها مواقع على الارض الاوكرانيه لها سنه
كامله تبني وواقع دفاعيه حتى لا تستطيع
اكرانيا استعادتها الفرق الزمني بين الوقت
الحاضر الذي اعلن به بايدا والدول
الاوروبيه انهم سوف يقدم لي اوكرانيا مثل
هذه الاليات وهذه الدبابات والاسلحه
العزائد الدوله
المدراعات المدوبه على فكره يعني الدبابات
لا تكون لوحده لا بد ان يكون معها مشاليه
لها ناقلات جنود مختلفه عن ما همم تحمله
همم الدبابات وبالتالي اعتقد ان الفرق
الزمني هذا ثلاث شهور اربع شهور حتى يصبح
الجندي الاوكراني قادرا على استخدامها هذا
السلاح هذه الفتره الزمنيه هي اللي صالح
روسيا وبالتالي ستستطيع ان تبني وتتقدم
وتحسن مواقعها واعتقد ان هذه النقطه
خلافيه الان في المجتمعات العسكريه
والقاده العسكريين الغربيين خاصه ما يتعلق
في المانيا انا اعتقد ان المانيا عندما
قال
بانه لا يرغب بالتصعيد ما معنى التصعيد في
هذه الحاله انت تقدم السلاح الذي يستطيع
ان يقتل الجندي الروسي وبالتالي هنالك
مثلا همم
بطاريات الباتريوات في بولندا اذا وصل
الصاروخ الى الاراضي الروسيه معناته النتو
دخل الحرب ضد روسيا نحن نعلم ان روسيا
تقاتل النت و34 دوله ولكن على الارض
الاوكرانيه امام الروج جنود اوكرانيين
ماذا لو قاد الدبابات والمدفع داخل
الدبابه على فكره كل دبابات تحتاج الى
اربعه
افراد لتشغيلها لكن دبابه سي في 90 سويديه
فيها طاقمين يعني فردين وبالتالي هنالك
اذا كان استخدام الجنود من النيته لتدريب
على الاوكرانيين على الاستخدام والقتال
على ارض المعركه هنا يقع المحذور الذي همم
يعني روسيا
ضد روسيا همم استاذ همم ياسين همم يعني
همم استنادا الى الى ما ذكره الاستاذ عصام
همم الجميع يقول بيض يقول ان هذه الدبابات
ليست للمواجهه همم اولاف شولدس يعني بصوت
مخلوق تقريبا نحن نمنع التصعيد لا نريد ان
نصل الى تصعيد والى حرب بين النت وروسيا
لكن هل عمليه
الانخراط الغربي هذا الشكل بهذه الطريقه
اليوم في تسليح اوكرانيا همم هو يعني
بمكان مع انه ال- ال- الحرب واقعه
هو بشكل عام الدول همم دول الحلفانيه زائد
دول مثل كوريا واليابان واستراليا الجميع
الدول اللي عدتهم اكثر 52 دوله داخلون في
هذه الحرب ضد روسيا ان روسيا تحارب اكثر
من 250 دوله
الحقيقه ان الوضع الميداني واعطاء
الدبابات الى اوكرانيا هي فقط لاسترجاع
الاراضي التي همم احتلتها روسيا بعد 24
فبراير من العام الماضي اي ان هذا تلك
الدبابات لا تستطيع في وقتها في وقتنا
الحالي ضرب العمق الروسي او ضبط الحدود
الروسيه لان اقليم الدنفاس بشكل عام يمتد
الى اكثر من 350 كيلو متر داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه يعني ان القادات الدبابات لا
يمكن ان تصل الى داخل الاراضي الروسيه
اعطاء الدبابات لاوراني هو الاسترجاع هذه
المدن التي تم اعتدادها من قبل الجيش
الروسي بالاضافه الى الى المعنويات لدى
الجيش الاوكراني على الناحيه الاخرى
احتلال مدينه سوليدار وتقدم الجيش الروسي
مع قوات بارنه ناحيه ضخمود ومن ثم اكرامي
كورس وسلبياتي هذه المدن تم اختلالها قبل
بدايه الربيع او قبل قدوم هذه الدبابات
التي نحتاج الى ثلاثه الى اربعه اشهر
يعطي دفعه معنويه لدى الشعب الروسي يعطي
دفعه معنويه لا القياده الروسيه ودخول
المانيا بشكل خاص واريد اكرر على خلق هذه
المواجهه واعطاها الدبابات نعلم ان الشعب
الروسي لديه حساسيه كبيره
الشعب الالماني وخاصه الذكر الاليمه همم
27 مليون روسي سقطه اثناء الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وما زالت الذكرى هذه دائما تتكرر
من التاسع
لذلك اعتقد ان الاسلحه التي مدت بها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المانيا
اوكرانيا هي اسلحه دفاعيه بعض النساء كيف
يمكن ان يقتنع الروسي بهذا الكلام يعني
السفير الروسي مثلا في واشنطن في تعليقه
همم كتب همم
على فيسبوك اذا قررت الولايات المتحده
تسليم دبابات فسيكون من المستحيل تبرير
مثل هذا العمل بحجه انها اسلحه دفاعيه
سيكون ذلك استفزازا جديدا صرخا موجا ضد
روسيا الاتحاديه لازم يفوتين الرئيس
الروسي واعتقد انه بالامكان ان نستمع
اليها همم جاد لو سمحت الرئيس السوري
الروسي قال ان القوات الامريكيه المتبرجه
في الامان هي قوات الاحتلال اا ساحاول ان
افهم ان كان هذا الكلام يمهد لشيء ما همم
لكن نستمع للرئيس الروسي همم بدايه
ستروبري
ومن الناحيه القانونيه
فان القوات الاحتلال الامريكيه موجوده على
اراضي جمهوريه المانيا الاتحاديه
والواقع ان هناك الكثير منها
[موسيقى]
يقولون ان المانيا لم تكن ابدا دوله ذات
سياده بالمعنى الكامل للكلمه
الكثير مما يحدث له جذور عميقه
وبالتاكيد سياتي الوقت الذي تستعد فيه
اوروبا سيادتها بطريقه ما
استاذ انديان ما الذي تفهمه من هذا الكلام
للرئيس الروسي وايضا كل التعليقات الروسيه
على الخطوه الامريكيه والغربيه عموما
اليوم
المثل العربي شروا البلديه ما يضحك يتكلم
الرئيس بوتن عن القوانين الدوليه وهو اول
من ضرب كل هذه القوانين في عرض الحائط من
خلال غزوه لاوكرانيا والتمرير هذا الغاز
على انه عمله عسكريه بسيطه لحمايه بعض
القوميات الروسيه في في شرق همم اوكرانيا
طبعا يعني يستطيع الرئيس الروسي قول ما
يريد وهذه القوات الامريكيه متواجده في
المانيا ليس من اليوم انما بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وهناك قواعد عسكريه
امريكيه في المانيا تزيد عن 200 قاعده وهي
ثاني اكبر قواعد عسكريه في العالم بعد
اليابان والا سينما في جزيره كيماوي هذا
من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى طبعا يعني هذه
الدبابات سواء كانت الدبابات
هي تقاتل في الاراضي الاوكرانيه دفاعا من
الاساسيات الاخرانيه وهي لا تقاتل على
اراضي روسيه حتى ولو اعتبر لو سلمنا جدلا
يعني واستراضا ان مناطق الاربعه لاسيما
الدنياسكو خيرسون والوهاس وزبارودجا تعتبر
بين هلالين يعني تعتبر اراضي همم روسيه
همم لا احد يعترف بها الا الروس كان ان
اراضي روسيه وبالتالي حسب القانون الدولي
هي ما زالت تخضع لسياده الاوكرانيه ويحق
لاوكرانيا ان تحرر هذه المناطق الاربعه من
الاحتلال الروسي وبالتالي يعني همم
نركز على وجهه نظر روسيه فقط ولكن يجب
علينا ان ننظر الى هذه الامور او الشعب من
مستوى الماكر وليس مستوى
المايكروبالتالي طبعا همم استاذ عصام همم
في في عمان همم
روسي عسكريا همم تزال لا تزال الاقوى همم
اليوم
في هذه المواجهه حقيقه حقيقه يعني انا
ارجو انك تعطيني بعض الوقت ليفسر بعض اللي
تفضلوا فيه الاخوه وعلى احترم ما قالوا
لكن يعني روسيا دوله عظمى يعني اقول يعني
هي يعني حربها في اوكرانيا
الاسترجاعي لاسترجاعي الدور السوفياتي
الماضي الذي كان في مرضى باسم روسيا
الاتحاديه واعاده الترتيب النظام الدولي
الجديد هذه النقطه هذه الناحيه السياسيه
نبحث فيها فيما بعد لكن دعيني اقول مفهوم
ان الدبابات اذا اتت الى اوكرانيا ستعيد
السيطره وتهزم الروس ويعتقد انه بالمفهوم
العسكري مفهوم الخاطئ لان تجميع هذه
الدبابات وبعد اربعه شهور ثم استخدامها من
قبل الاوكرانيين لا يمكن ان يكون على درجه
عاليه من الكف تشغيليه اضافه الى القدره
على الصيام الميدانيه وتوفر الامدادات
اللوجستيه لهذه الاليات والدبابات
المتنوعه سواء كانت تشالنجر البريطاني يا
ابرامز الامريكيه ليوباردي الالمانيه
سيفيا السويديه او الداعيه او الدبابات
عالميه يمكن ان تعطى لاوكرانيا لا يمكن ان
تهزم من رؤوس الان بعد هذه المده الزمنيه
انا اعتقد انا لست مع روسيا ضد اوكرانيا
ولا مع اوكرانيا انا رجل عسكري احلل ما
يجري على الارض وبالتالي انا اقول انه
يمكن يمكن
الدبابات اذا تم استخدامها بطريقه
استراتيجيه
وتفتيكيه عملياتيه على الارض
بطريقه تستطيع ان تستعيد بعض المواقع هذا
يحتاج الى انا من استخدام وكفاءه
المتدربين عليها اما اذا قلنا ان والله
رفع معنويات الاوكرانيين لا اطلاقا لانه
عندما يركبها الجندي الاوكراني سيتوجز
خيفه من استخدامها لانه لم يتعود على هذا
النوع من الاليات المعقده ذات التقنيه
العاليه اضافه الى ان وحده السيطره
والقياده في مثل هذه الاليات التقنيه
العاليه همم
التكنولوجيا يمكن ان تشكل هذه سن يخاف منه
الجندي الاوكراني لانه لم يعتاد على هذه
التقنيه لو كانت قبل نشوب الحرب
هذه القدره على التدريب واستخدامها كائن
اعتقد انه يمكن ان يحدث فرقا اما
كثير دبابات
كتائب دبابات لا تستطيع ان تخلي الروس
اقليم دون بارك اطلاقا لانه
ثلاثه
هذه
الدبابه تحديدا
باسهاب واعطيتنا الكثير من التفاصيل في
الواقع الغنيه جدا والمتريه لكن الان ااه
يعني هناك سؤال حول ربما لحظه بما انه
الوضع همم يعني مشدود لهذه الدرجه وروسيا
تهدد بانها اصلا كانت تهدد بانها ستدمر كل
اي سلاح يصل الى كيف ايضا بخصوص هذه
النقطه استاذ عصام تعتقد بانه روسيا قادره
على تدمير بسرعه كل هذا العتاد القوي الذي
تمد به يموت به الغربي سؤال والله مهم جدا
لكن اذا نظرنا الى الاستخدام ابرامز
واليومبارد في افغانستان سوريا ماذا فعلت
ما زال الافغان موجودين طالبان السعاده
الحكم همم خرجت بامريكا من افغانستان
بطريقه مخذيه ما الوضع في سوريا على ما هو
عليه لم تحقق لو بعد اثنين ولا ابرامز اي
شيء على الارض السوريه هذا يعني ان روسيا
كانت متواجده في
الاراضي السوريه وكانت متواجده بمساعداتها
لطالبان وبعض المقاومين للغرب سعرا من
هزيمتها في افغانستان في السبعينات اذا
نوعيه الاليه قد لا تكون قادره لان طبيعه
الارض طبيعه الارض احنا الان لقاء نقول ان
هذه الاليات جاءت لتقاتل ولكن عندما نرى
ان الدروع تقاتل في المناطق المبنيه هذا
مقتل للدروع والدبابات
وللاليات المدرعه يجب ان يكون هنالك تقنيه
وتفتيك جديد هو استخدام اسلحه الميم دال
المضاده للدروع يجب تعليمها هؤلاء الجنود
كيفيه اقتناس الاليات
والدبابات الروسيه داخل المناطق المبنيه
اما التركوه فنقول انهم سيستعيدوا اعتقد
ان ذلك يعني صعب جدا انا لست معي يعني
وفلان او ضد هلا ابدا ابدا
واضح استاذ عصام شبر مع ياسين همم برايك
يعني بمسار الحرب همم ما هي اللحظه
الخطيره التي تخشاها برلين همم
الى اي مدى بالفعل هناك يعني شعور بان
الامور قد تفلت في لحظه ما وان ما تخشاه
من مواجهه بين روسيا وبنات وقد يحصل همم
هناك نقاش همم فعلا جدي وحول هذه المساله
ام انه امر مستبعد بالرغم من كلام
المستشار همم
اعتقد ان الامر مستعد حاليا
لذا روسيا الان سلاح الغاز اييه المانيا
تستورد ما زالت تستورد الغاز من
روسيا بنسبه 9% اعتقد انه يمكن الضغط على
المانيا وملح هذه 9% ايضا قال انه يمكن
يمكن يجب ان يبحث على مصادر اخرى للغاز
مواجهه ما بين روسيا بمعنى الكلمه هي
حاليا موجوده بمعنى الكلمه ان روسيا ودول
الناتج جميعا يتصارعون على الارض
الاوكرانيه وهي معركه كسر عظام الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تستخدم الدول الاوروبيه
لاستنزاف
الدب الروسي والاستنزاف الدول الاوروبيه
الاقتصاد الاوروبي بشكل عام منهج نسب
التضخم عاليه نسب البطاله عاليه وارتفاع
الاسعار ارتفاع اسعار الوقود وارتفاع
اسعار الكهرباء كل ذلك في اوروبا بين ان
هناك دعوات من قبل الرئيس البلغاري على
سبيل المثال وبعض السياسيين في الدول
الاوروبيه الا انه لا يجب ان نمد اوكرانيا
بهذه باسلحه متطوره حتى لا يزداد امل هذه
الحرب حيث ومن ثم سيزداد سوء الوضع
الاقتصادي في الاتحاد الاوروبي بشكل عام
اعتقد ان الوضع الاقتصادي
سيكون مهيمنا على الوضع السياسي قريبا
خصوصا بعد ان بعد انتهاء فصل الشتاء الان
ستبدا ستتحتاج المانيا الان الى استيراد
الغاز لديها مخزونات معينه يكفيها لنهايه
شهر اثنين ومن ثم ستبحث عن المبرزين
القادم الى الى المانيا الوضع الاقتصاد
تلعب دور كبيره افهم ان اوكرانيا تطالب
بكثير من الاسلحه وذلك فقط للدفاع عن
ارضها ولكن مخزونات ومستودعات الاسلحه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي اصبحت فارغه وحتى ان
انجازات الدبابات هذه الى اوكرانيا بدون
وجود طائرات لا يمكن لا يمكن ان تلعب دورا
كبيرا مهما يوجد هذه الدبابات على الارض
لانها تحتاج الى طائرات الحمايه الدبابه
ست اسحاق يعني همم يقول همم الاستاذ شبرما
بانه همم امريكا تستنزف همم تحاول استنزاف
في روسيا وتستنزف في نفس الوقت اوروبا
بمكان بمكان ما همم همم
برايك همم يعني همم الولايات المتحده
مستفيده من ان يطول هذا النزاع في
اوكرانيا
حول التهديدات الروسيه للدول الاوروبيه
لاعتقد ان هذه التهديدات سيتم يعني
ترجمتها عمليه على الارض باستثناء على
الاراضي الاخرانيه لانه في حال امتدت بقعه
المواجهات الى دول اوروبيه اخرى سوف يفعل
ذلك الماده الخامسه من معاهده الميتو اي
معاهده الدفاع المشترك وعند ادم سيكون
اعلان حرب مباشر من قبل الروس على كل دول
وعندنا اذا تتغير قواعد اللعبه الكليه لان
سبق وقام الروس بتهديد عده مرات لاسيما في
الصيف الماضي عندما كانت الولايات المتحده
ترسل همم الجامع الانتريه
الى الى اوروبا عبره بولندا سبق
للروس ان هدده بضرب هذه القوافل التي تحمل
همم هذه الصواريخ ولكن
هذا الامر محصوره في الكلام حرب الكلاميه
اكثر
ادم الناعي الناحيه اخرى طبعا الولايات
المتحده لديها مصلحه استراتيجيه في
استنزاف الروس لكي تحاول ان تضعفها من
الداخل
وهناك امور اخرى يعني صبغه وتكلم بها
ايطاليا
انهم يحاولون اسم نزار الروس
مباشر هو اطاله امد الحرب لكي يعني ان
يستسلم احد اطراف الحرب وبالتالي تدعم
الولايات المتحده والغرب يدعمونا اوكرانيا
في مواجهه روسيه لكي يصل الى مرحله ترفع
العشره روسيه ترفع العشره كما يقال لو
طبعا هذا لم يحدث برائه لان هذه المساله
لن تحسم ولن تحل الا من خلال مفاوضات ومن
خلال تقديم تناجلات من خلال طرفين يعني
على روسيه تقدم تنازلات معينه وعلى
اوكرانيا ان تقدم ايضا تنازلات مؤلمه قد
تكون مؤلمه بعض الشيء من خلال همم
السيطره على بعض الاراضي همم الاساسيه في
منطقتي
استاذ عصام هناك من يعتبر
من الاسئله حول الامكان بالفعل ممكن ان
تذهب الامور الى ابعد وان نشهد مواجهه بين
روسيا همم لكن هناك من يعتبر بان او او
الوصول الى عالميه ثالثه هناك من يعتبر
الحرب العالميه الثالثه قائمه همم تحدث
بالفعل همم حضرتك بان لك بما انك عينت
الكثير من الحروب على ما اعتقد همم
يعني كيف يمكن ان توصف هذه الحرب الدائره
اليوم هل هي فعلا حرب تقليديه همم هل هي
حرب يعني كيف يمكن اتصفها همم وان لم يكن
هناك مواجهه الجندي اطلسي مقابل جندي روسي
بانها ما زالت حرب تقليديه مع النظر او
فتح مستودعات الاسلحه غير التقليديه لاي
ظرف طارق يمكن ان يحدث في اي لحظه لكن
يعني همم
كلام عن ما يجري على الارض انا اعتقد ان
روسيا لديها همم
التخطيط العسكري المعاد سلفا لما يمكن ان
تقول اليه الحرب
بينما
بعندماته لم يكونوا يتصوروا ان هذه تطور
الى هذا المستوى وبالتالي هم يعني اصبحوا
في ما يسمى
تامين همم العسكري من ناحيه القطط في رده
فعل او في مرحله تردده الفعل وليس بالفعل
بمعنى صاحب المبادره القوات الروسيه اثنين
يعني انا اعتقد ان وكل الغربيين وكل
المحللين العسكريين يقولوا ان الانتصار في
هذه المعركه بالمفهوم العسكري غير وارد
اذا نحن امام حاله من الاشتباك العسكري
العنيف الذي سيؤدي في النهايه من الجلوس
الى طاوله المفاوضات هنا نقول لماذا لا
يعي العقل الغربي العسكري هذه المقوله
ويقوم بدور همم الوسيط وليس الداعم لاشعال
للحرب واعتقد ان فرنسا والرئيس الفرنسي ما
زال حذرا جدا في عمليه التزويد لاوكرانيا
بالاسلحه ومازال يحافظ على قناه الاتصال
مع الرئيس بوتن اذا هل يمكن ان نقول ان
هناك همم امكانيه للجلوس على طاوله
المفاوضات
ونكون يعني قد عملنا بما يسمى بعلم
السياسه الوين وين وين جيم يعني عن يشعر
كل طرف من الاطراف بانه منتصر لكن انا
اقول ان انسحاب روسيا الى شرق نهر هذا
يعني ان الروس قد
يعني همم حققوا ما يريدوا وبالتالي هم
يضعوا الخطوط النهائيه للاراضي التي يريد
البقاء فيها اوكرانيا سواء كان بان
جمهوريات مستقله عن اوكرانيا
بحكما ذاتي ذات استقلاليه عاليه جدا قد
يكون انسحابهم مشروط
بالاعتراف بهذه الجمهوريات ما عدم وجود
الروس ولكن ستكون علاقات وطيده بين روسيا
واقليم جول بس مع البقاء في جزيره في شبه
الجزيره
لسه هتفاوض على هذا الحدود ام اوروبا ام
امريكا التي ستفاوض على هذه الحدود
دعينا اكون معك واضح اوكرانيا هي الواجهه
التي همم نسمعها ونراها ولكن الذي يقود
هذه المواجهه من الخلف امريكا وحلف الناتو
لذلك اوكرانيا لا تستطيع ان تستمر هذه
المده من الزمن في قتلها امام روسيا لولا
الدعم الامريكي
همم يعني بالنسبه للموقف الفرنسي همم هل
تعتقد بانه بالفعل ممكن ان لا تذهب فرنسا
باتجاه منح لوكلاغ ايضا دبابات لكلاغ
لديها همم
اكياس على غرار الغربيين بينما اسبانيا
تقول بانها سترسل ايضا دبابات التي لديها
همم راينا قبل قليل الدنمارك كذلك
بريطانيا تقول تحس الغربيين بارسال همم
يعني دبابات ثقيله اكثر
تعتقد بان فرنسا ممكن ان لابقاء قناه
مفتوحه مع بوتن ان لا تذهب بهذا الاتجاه
مع الاوروبيين الباقين
من الاسلحه الى طرف الاوكراني بقيت موضوع
الدبابات التصريحات الرئيس الفرنسي
اكد انه سيقوم بارسال الدبابات لاحقا
لا اعتقد ان الان سقطت جميع جميع الاقنعه
يعني صح التعبير لا يوجد هناك دوله في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ترغب في الجلوس مع
الرئيس الروسي الذي هم يبعثون على الاسلحه
الى اوكرانيا حتى تستطيع القياده
الاوكرانيه من السيطره على بعض الاراضي
والضغط على روسيا للجلوس الى المفاوضات
ضد الاخر روسيا ستعتمد على سياسه انها
ستحتل كامل اراضي اقليم بس اراضي هذه
الجمعيات الاربعه ومن ثم نصف اسلحه
400 واسهل 3
والمدرعات وجعل هذه الحدود هي حدود رسميه
داخل اطار حول الروسيه هناك اجتماع كان
قبل اسبوعين لرئيس بوت مع رؤساء الولايات
الداخليه في الاتحاد الروسي وقال ان هذه
الجمهوريه الاربعه هي الاراضي روسيه
وسنقوم من الان حتى عام 2030 باصلاح البن
التحتيه شامله واعطاء دفعه معنويه وماديا
لهذه الجمهوريه العربيه حتى تصبح اراضي
روسيا مشابهه للعراق او روسيه التي
تمتلكها الروس الاتحاد حاليا
فرنسا هذه الدبابات او لم ترسلها لن يغير
الوضع على الحالي اعتقد الرئيس بوت يعني
همم جيدا ان الاتحاد الاوروبي داخل هذه
الحرب اذا جانب الولايات المتحده بكل قوه
حتى لازم ضروري يعني التقليل من اهميه
حصول ايضا الاكياف على هذه على هذا النوع
من الدبابات همم هل هو منطقي يعني هل هو
هل هو يعني صحيح
هم لم يقلل العروس من هذه الدبابات بالعكس
المستشار
الروسيات الذي قال عنها الرئيس
الروسي
ولكن ارسال هذه الكميه الكبيره من الاسلحه
الى اوكرانيا يعني ذلك انهم الان في مرحله
ثانيه من الحرب بعد ان كانت المرحله هي
المرحله دفاعيه الان اصبحت مرحله هجوميه
فينا نقول وبالتالي دخلت هذه الحرب في
منعطف جديد همم استاذ شبرما لاشراك مع
اعلان همم الغربيين اليوم بماده كيف بهذا
النوع من الدبابات
سنختم الان نقاش انا بنهايه وقت هذا
النقاش اشكرك همم الكاتب الصحفي المختص
بسهوله الاوروبيه
شكرا جزيلا لايك استاذ عصام ملكاوي استاذ
دراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
والخبير العسكري الذي افادنا كثيرا اليوم
واسرع نقاشه شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر من مدينه
اتلانتا ايضا همم المشاركه اللطيفه لاسحاق
انديكيان الاكاديمي والباحث في اداره
النزاعات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ
اسحاق الشكر لكم مشاهدينا شكرا لوفائكم
[موسيقى]